intensifying the CIA director
says the next few months will be
crucial for the outcome.
>> I think the next six months
it seems to me, and it's our
assessment at CIA, are going to
be critical.
Putin I think is betting right
now that he can make time work
for him.
He is betting that he can grind
down Ukrainians, that political
fatigue is going to set in.
We do not assess that Putin is
serious about negotiations.
The key is on the battlefield in
the next six months it seems to
us.
Puncturing Putin's hubris.
Making clear he is not going to
be able to advance further in
Ukraine, but as every month goes
by he runs a greater and greater
risk of losing the territory
that he has illegally seized
from Ukraine so far.
>> I want to bring in the former
European affairs director at the
national security council
retired lieutenant colonel Alex
vin man, the author of here
right matters an American story.
Thank you so much for joining me
this morning.
Good to talk to you.
I wonder what you made of the
assessment from the CIA
director.
>> I think that the ambassadors
and director's assessment is
very, very good.
My question is, what are we
doing to make this very critical
next six months increasingly
difficult for Vladimir Putin.
The fact is that this next six
months the Russians are going to
potentially start another
offensive, take more territory.
The Ukrainians are going to have
to blunt that attack and move on
the offensive and start to take
territory.
These slow flows of tanks, the
fact that we are providing
Abrams and they won't get there
for six months is not
sufficient.
Signaling those tanks coming
just to release the German
leopard tanks and other
countries providing tanks is
not -- that's a what happened in
2008.
We signaled we wanted Ukraine to
join nato and all that did was
precipitate Russia's increased
aggression.
We have to take firm action
which is provide Ukraine the
equipment it needs, that
includes planes, drones, that
includes accelerating the pace
of the delivery of these tanks,
and that can be done.
It's just a matter of will.
>> And you said you believe the
flow of this equipment and these
weapons to Ukraine is kind of
resulting in this incremental
escalation.
You write in foreign affairs
that western reluctance to fully
support Ukraine and defeat
Russia undercuts Ukraine's
ability to conduct an offends
and cause the war to stretch
deep into 2023.
It seems like you are saying if
it they provided more sooner,
this could end sooner?
>> That's very true.
But I am also concerned about
the future.
It's not just the fact that we
allowed this war to stretch out
many, many months more than it
needs to be.
It's that the next six, nine
months are going to be
particularly dangerous.
We are probably going to face an
increasingly erratic Vladimir
Putin where he believes that his
crown jewel, the crimea
peninsula, is going to be under
threat and what actions he takes
then.
I feel very confident in saying
he is not going to escalate to
any nuclear options because that
would be the end of his regime.
That's the point he starts to
really seriously consider that
option.
Not just threaten it.
Not just to use that as a means
to get the west to back down,
but starts to consider the
option seriously.
If that's the biggest thing we
want to avoid, this potential
existential crisis, we need to
make sure we don't go this road
of incremental escalation and
give the Ukrainians what they
need, the means to threaten the
peninsula and then force Putin
to negotiate in earnest, like
the director of central
intelligence said, he is not
serious yet.
He will absolutely get serious
when crimea is under threat and
the Ukrainians liberate more
territory.
The sooner we get there, the
less chance of escalation and
less risk to spill over into a
confrontation with nato.
>> You think the U.S. Should
send the fighter jets?
>> We should be training the
Ukrainians on fighter jets.
If we keep saying that it takes
months and months to prepare the
Ukrainians for these advanced
capabilities, which it does, we
should be training them now on
the prospect they may need them
six months from now.
We should have been doing the
tank training a long time ago.
What disturbs me, symptoms come
in without logistical support.
All the support that the
Ukrainians get, they get it
outside of Poland.
Everything else is done through
what we call telemedicine, you
call up and show the Ukrainians
what's broken on a screen and
they have to say, okay, well, we
need these parts and it takes a
look time to get systems fixed.
Supporting a war from 800
kilometers away is
unsustainable.
We need to provide logistics.